so the entire criminal policy of the
left of the hard left is that there are
certain people who they don't think
should be in jail therefore no one
should be in jail apparently according
to the new york post manhattan's new d.a
has now ordered his prosecutors to stop
seeking prison sentences for hordes of
criminals and to downgrade felony
charges in cases including armed
robberies and drug dealing according to
a set of progressive policies made
public on tuesday
in his first memo to staff on monday
alvin bragg said his office quote will
not seek a carceral sentence meaning put
people in jail except for homicide in a
handful of other cases including
domestic violence felonies some sex
crimes and public corruption
this rule may be accepted only in
extraordinary circumstances based on
holistic analysis of the facts criminal
history victims input and any other
information available the memo reads
assistant das must also now keep in mind
the impacts of incarceration including
whether it really does increase public
safety potential future barriers to
convicts involving housing and
employment the financial cost of prison
and and the racial disparities over who
gets time now again we are making rules
for the entire society based on a small
minority of people who commit criminal
acts that's what we are doing
by the way minorities are the minorities
because when we talk about oh there are
too many black men going to prison that
is still a vast minority of black men
the vast majority of black men do not go
to prison
and there's this baseline idea that we
have to completely reshape how criminal
law and institutions of justice are done
in this country because you don't like
the outcome for a minority of humans who
decide to commit crimes is patently
crazy
but that is what they are seeking to do
because the idea is that we have created
a quote-unquote carceral society and our
constitutional society is having
downstream effects that shape how people
live and we don't like how those people
are living and therefore we have to get
rid of these institutions all together
we've done that but guess what replaces
it chaos when you get rid of
institutions you create new institutions
those new institute institutions either
foster chaos or foster tyranny or both
when it comes to criminal law the left
is fostered to absolute anarchy chaos
is why you've seen mass increases in
murder rates across major cities in the
united states because prosecutors have
decided that they are not interested in
prosecuting people on behalf of the
small minority so just as the
institution of marriage must be
destroyed because there are some people
who don't like it and they don't fit
within the box and the institutions of
law must be destroyed because there are
some people who don't like the law and
commit crimes
and the institution of gender must be
destroyed because there are some people
who feel uncomfortable
and of course we have to destroy the
institution of schooling as well because
there are some people who feel
uncomfortable so for example the chicago
public schools have now canceled all
classes because the union voted to go
virtual now we have been told by the
biden administration
that public sector unions are a are a
fulsome good they are excellent and we
need public sector unions that bargain
against the taxpayer
we need this they're very important
and we need to make sure that these
teachers who are the heroes of the
pandemic after i mean soldiering on
soldiering on from their homes and
apartments doing zoom classes to a bunch
of kids who aren't watching them they
are the true heroes they are they are
truly the heroes now listen there are
some teachers who actually tried to go
back into school and those people
are just as heroic as everybody else who
went to work no more no less you're not
more heroic for having gone into a
school than the guy is for having gone
into a factory or even the banker is for
having gone into his office today
this silliness where teachers are more
heroic than every other member of the
population is really foolish when it
comes to omicron when it comes to when
it comes to covet generally considering
the kids are not getting sick
you're more likely to get sick
at your local factory working than you
are likely to get sick at your local
school working this has been true
throughout the pandemic by the way
in fact you remember that last summer
when delta was beginning to spike
there's all this thought well if we
reopen schools teachers are going to get
sick and it turned out that every story
that was coming up about teachers dying
was from a teacher who got infected
outside of school
and well now the chicago teachers union
the greatest of all people who are
running the biden administration by the
way randy weingarten is in the white
house every other minute
the chicago teachers union voted to
teach virtually rather than in the
classroom because of course these are
heroes heroes of the republic cps is the
third largest school district in the
country they resumed in-person learning
on monday in conditions that union
leaders described as unsafe
the union held an emergency meeting on
tuesday the vote was 73
in favor of the remote work only job
action the union said on twitter
chicago chicago public schools described
the union vote as quote an unfortunate
decision
the union said the action will end when
the current surging cases substantially
subsides
okay so just a quick note this is an
illegal strike okay by by law public
sector unions are not allowed to strike
the reason they're not allowed to strike
is because they're not striking against
an employer they're striking against the
taxpayer public sector unions are barred
from strikes by law doesn't matter they
do it all the time
but again the idea is the rules must
change the rules must change because
there's a small group of people who are
paranoid and being crazy
and so all the rules have to change to
restrict students from being able to go
to school
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feet